bonjour je suis né à la microbiologie
juste à la charnière entre pasteurs et
la biologie moléculaire
c'était à peu près en 1986 87 quand on
commençait à faire de biologie
moléculaire dans les laboratoires et moi
qui avais appris à l'école faire de la
microbiologie pasteurienne un peu comme
ça devant une flamme avec une boîte
c'est ce sont des boîtes de culture
qu'on appelle des gels aux en fait ça
ressemble mugello cela ressemble un peu
à une panacotta améliorées pour les
bactéries bon n'essayez pas d'en
consommer quand même c'est assez
dangereux puisque chaque petit point que
vous voyez sur cette boîte ça représente
une bactérie qui a poussé pendant trois
jours et qui chaque petit point
représente à peu près un milliard de
bactéries comme celle-là est pathogène
je vous déconseille de la consommer mais
on a j'étais un petit peu à la frontière
entre deux mondes et on a vu apparaître
des techniques qui étaient très
différentes des techniques pasteurienne
chargé de technologie et je vais essayer
de vous expliquer comment ces techniques
sont apparus et qu'est-ce que comment on
peut redonner du sens avec toutes ces
technologies qui nous qui nous entoure
j'allais dire qui nous envahissent mais
pas du tout qui nous servent tous les
jours justement pour mieux garantir la
sécurité de vos assiettes
comment comment avec ces technologies on
peut redonner du sens à la biologie et
finalement ce avoir plutôt une plus
grosse puissance de travail que tu avoir
peur de ces technologies à travers pour
pour vous décrire ça je vais vous parler
dans un premier temps d'une bactérie
qu'on appelle campylobacter qu'on aime
beaucoup nous les microbiologistes alors
ça vous dit rien comme ça n'est pas très
joli mais en fait elle est un petit peu
torsadé d'habitude d'une bactérie c'est
un bâton ça ressemble à un car en sac ou
albi et celle ci est un peu torsadé puis
surtout on aime bien parce qu'elle va
très vite elle voit à peu près huit fois
plus vite que sean boltz et des
bactéries les plus rapides du monde est
alors bon je vous dirais un petit peu
après ce qu'elle fait vous serez
certainement moins séduit cette bactérie
on a commencé à l'étudier avec les
méthodes que j'ai évoquées précédemment
précédemment tu
on a eu des microscopes un peu plus
perfectionnés pour l'avoir ici un
microscope électronique et 7
cette bactérie a commencé à nous livrer
ses secrets
mais entre temps en 1953 il ya une
première révolution dans le domaine de
la biologie s'est pas passé il s'est
passé des choses évidemment entre entre
la fin du 19e siècle pasteur et puis
1953 mais en 1953 trois chercheurs est
une chercheuse dans les plus connus sont
watson et crick mais il y avait aussi
wilkins et puis que je n'oublie pas son
nom à franklyn qui était la femme qui a
été oublié en fait parce qu'elle est
décédée avant le prix nobel
c'est ces quatre chercheurs ont
découvert l'adn et ont découvert la
structure de l'adn est ce que nous on a
appelé les lettres de l'adn les quatre
lettres qui code pour tout notre code
génétique et ça ça a été une vraie
révolution le début d'une vraie
révolution même si on l'a pas compris
tout de suite
ensuite en 61 un chercheur qui s'appelle
nierenberg à trouver commence à ranger
les lettres entre elles par groupes de
trois ce qu'on appelait les co dont
c'est le mot il a inventé la syllabe en
quelque sorte et il a compris comment
ses syllabes s'arranger entre elles pour
laisser le champ ensuite en 1965 à lvov
jacob et mono trois chercheurs français
qui ont aussi eu le prix nobel ce sont
je ne parle que de prix nobel moi j'en
suis parent malheureusement trois
chercheurs français dont qui ont eu le
prix nobel en décodant la phrase ils ont
décodé ce qu'on appelle lé opérons
lactose en fait ils ont réussi à décoder
la phrase de l'adn qui permet à un
escherichia coli
le même qui a tué plein de plein de gens
en allemagne de consommer du lactose et
de de casser ce lactose pour produire de
l'énergie
et avec cette invention de la phrase on
a commencé à mieux comprendre comment
fonctionne et comment fonctionne l adn
ensuite en 1969 parfois les ruelles et
les recherches trouve pas forcément ce
qu'elles voulaient trouver un chercheur
qui s'appelle tous mus lice à travailler
sur une bactérie qu'on trouvait dans les
geysers donc était capable de pousser à
95 degrés vous savez que les bactéries
généralement elle pousse plutôt à 30 37
degrés voire un peu plus bas
voir un peu plus haut et 95° c'était
tout à fait exceptionnelle et dans cette
bactérie il a isolé une enzyme qui était
justement capable de résister à 95
degrés qui s'appelle la tacc polymérase
ça vous dira probablement pas grand
chose mais cette taxe polymérase pour
nous ça a été l'invention de
l'imprimerie
c'est une enzyme qui nous a permet de
reproduire l'adn en grande quantité et
très vite et de développer des
technologies qui ont mis 20 ans à se
développer entre le travail de mu lycées
et les les premiers appareils
mais voilà donc ça nous a permis
d'amplifier l'adn plutôt que d'amplifier
les bactéries quel est l'avantagé c'est
que l'adn simplifie beaucoup plus vite
avec cette taxe polymérase alors
l'inconvénient c'est qu'on a gagné en
efficacité mais nos laboratoires sont
devenus beaucoup moins poétique
ils se sont remplis de boîtes grises
avec des ordinateurs et notre monde
quotidien maintenant c'est celui ci
celui ci c'est un monde de boîte grise
avec des ordinateurs à côté mais on a
quand même gagné beaucoup en efficacité
en 77
on a autre révolution on a appris à lire
ses phrases
à lire ce qu'on avait imprimé et on a
été capable de séquencer l'adn c'est à
dire de découper laden en petits
morceaux avec des petits ciseaux ciseaux
moléculaires un peu compliqué mais ça
nous a permis de commencer à séquencer
l'adn et les premiers séquenceur sont
sortis en 77
ce qui a conduit de 90 à 2003 13 ans
quand même au décodage de l'adn humain
et puis en 2007 on a vu apparaître les
appareils que vous voyez derrière moi ce
qu'on appelle les séquenceurs haut débit
qui sont capables de faire ce travail
qu'on a fait en 16 ans en quelques jours
au maximum quelques semaines et donc
qu'ils sont capables de lire beaucoup
plus vite l'adn qu on le lisait avant
donc on a à peu près au cours de ces
cinquante années ouvert le livre ait
réussi à lire ce livre maintenant vous
allez me dire à quoi ça sert tout ça est
bien
revenons à notre campylobacter il ya 35
ans quand on a commencé à travailler sur
cette bactérie on savait pas trop ce
qu'elle signifiait on arrivait à peine à
la détecter on a commencé à mettre les
panna cotta au point pour pour la
détecter et désormais avec ces appareils
on arrive à la fois à la détecter et à
la découper en morceaux pour lire son
livre de l'adn en
quelques heures le revers de la médaille
c'est ce qu'on ne savait pas à l'époque
c'est que cette bactérie responsable à
peu près 500 mille dinars et parents en
france
alors justement à propos de diarrhée
rentrons un peu un peu plus loin dans ce
monde et pour un deuxième exemple je
vais vous parler de ces technologies à
quoi ils nous servent pour comprendre un
monde qui était jusque-là tout à fait
inconnu un peu comme le monde marin qui
est le microbiote digestif qu'est ce que
c'est que le microbiote digestif bien
avant pour d'abord le microbiote
digestif c'est certainement en nombre de
cellules le plus grand organe de notre
de notre organisme puisque c'est à peu
près dix mille milliards de bactéries
plus de 1000 espèces bactériennes le
microbiote qui va varier avec l'âge
varié avec l'alimentation avec le mode
de vie c'est un organe excessivement
complexe qui est très dépendant de notre
environnement et notamment de ce qu'on
mange on peut sans on peut s'en douter
alors 10% de ce microbiote à peu près
est cultivable avec des techniques comme
celle que vous voyez à l'écran des
techniques de culture en anaérobie parce
que ce sont des bactéries qui ne
supportent pas l'oxygène plus de dix
minutes
et donc on l'est on les cultive dans une
atmosphère qui contient de l'hydrogène
pour avoir fait sa une partie de ma vie
je peux vous dire que c'est assez
pénible on est on est rapidement
transpirant parce qu'il fait 37 degrés
au niveau des mains mais bon c'est cette
une technique qu'on utilise encore on en
est encore besoin mais on a maintenant
d'autres technologies pour le faire
alors pour autant le tube digestif c'est
assez joli à l'intérieur finalement vous
avez ici un tube digestif de volaille
avec toutes les flores qui peuvent qu on
peut y trouver
et vous voyez que femme pour nous
biologistes qui avons peu le sens de
l'esthétique il faut bien le dire nous
trouvons ça très joli mais c'est
technique là évidemment elles ne
permettent pas de comprendre tout ce que
tout ce qui se passe toutes les
interactions qui se passe entre ces
bactéries à quoi servent ces bactéries
et et pour le comprendre
on a de nouveau ces machines qui nous
permettent de faire un séquençage de
tout ce qu'il y a en fait dans le tout
l'adn qui est présent dans un tube
digestif et de reconnaître plus
facilement les différentes espèces alors
c'est quoi à l'application de tout ça
l'application c'est que ça nous permet
de comprendre les équilibres du tube
digestif et aussi malheureusement ces
déséquilibres
quand on mange quelque chose qui
contient une bactérie qui ne devraient
pas y être
ça nous permet aussi de comprendre
comment on va pouvoir diminuer
l'utilisation d'antibiotiques pour
éviter que par exemple pour les animaux
sur lesquels nous on travaille éviter
que ces animaux soient malades sans
utiliser d'antibiotiques la
compréhension de ce monde digestif nous
va beaucoup nous aider
chez l'homme par exemple on a trouvé
récemment que la composition de la flore
digestive était très étroitement liées à
certains types de diabète de type 2
alors est ce que c'est la poule ou
l'oeuf ça on ne sait pas encore est ce
que c'est le diabète qui fait qu'on a
une flore digestive différentes
ou est ce que c'est parce qu'on a une
flore digestive différentes qu'on ait
plus ou plus ou moins sujets au diabète
très certainement un peu des deux ça
nous permet de mieux comprendre des
maladies complexes comme la maladie de
crohn par exemple qui est une maladie
gravé et qui est très certainement lié à
ces interactions entre les bactéries et
l'autre est le tube digestif de l'hôte
et donc on comprend mieux
en gros avec tout ça la présence de
bactéries pathogènes et pourquoi on a
ces bactéries pathogènes pourquoi dans
certains cas elles se multiplient
pourquoi elle ne se multiplient pas pour
revenir à notre campylobacter ce qu'on
sait toujours pas malgré toutes ces
techniques
c'est pourquoi les poulets en ont plein
et qui ne sont pas malades et pourquoi
dès que les gens en ont un peu ils sont
malades bon on essayera de le comprendre
à l'avenir alors pour travailler sur sur
toutes ses solutions technologiques
qu'on nous a offert le chercheur en
biologie il a changé de métier un petit
peu et surtout il a changé de
partenariat avant travailler dans une
équipe de recherche en biologie c'était
travailler entre soi entre biologistes
maintenant c'est travailler avec des
ingénieurs avec des informaticiens qu'on
appelle maintenant des bio
informaticiens parce que ces machines là
par exemple elles vont nous débiter en
24 heures entre 10 gigas et un terreau
habite de données et ces données là
évidemment il faut les analyser et pour
ça il faut des statisticiens des
informaticiens donc nos métiers ont
changé en ce sens qu'ils nous font
travailler à l'interface avec d'autres
mais
et avec des mondes relativement inconnu
pour les pour les biologistes et ça nous
permet de réaliser des sauts de
connaissances pour ne pas être
totalement sont les risques de tout ça
c'est que les questions de recherche
qu'on se pose ne soit plus conduite par
la recherche du cians du sens biologique
mais par la technologie on à la
technologie et on l'utilisent
j'ai un ami qui dit très souvent quand
on a un marteau tous les problèmes
prennent la forme d'un cloud et c'est
précisément ce qu'on veut éviter
précisément ce qu'on veut éviter en
biologie c'est l'essentiel c'est d'abord
de bien poser la bonne question
biologique et ensuite de chercher des
technologies qui vont bien pour y
répondre les bénéfices de tout ça c'est
que en comprenant tous les mécanismes au
mieux l'ensemble des mécanismes du
vivant on a progressé dans la lutte
contre les maladies infectieuses
on a découvert de nouveaux vaccins de
nouvelles thérapies de nouvelles
méthodes de prévention parfois qui sont
des préventions non médical si on
comprend mieux le microbiote digestif
on comprendra mieux quelles
alimentations va favoriser qu'elle
microbiote favorable plutôt que le
microbiote défavorable donc on a un
petit peu progressé quand même y compris
dans les techniques de prévention
après avec toutes ces technologies on
peut avoir le sentiment qu'on a fait le
tour de la question et que c'est la fin
de la recherche
alors ça c'est terrible pour les
chercheurs c'est pour ça qu'il ya plein
de chercheurs qui trouvent pas
d'ailleurs parce que parce que quand on
trouve il faut trouver un autre sujet
les et on peut avoir effectivement quand
des en ayant le sentiment qu'on ayant
décortiqué le message génétique on a
tout compris du vivant bien en fait la
nature nous apprend beaucoup l'humidité
et on commence à se rendre compte que
même quand on connaît le livre on n'a
pas interpréter toutes les phrases du
livre toutes les métaphores du livre et
que notre environnement par exemple va
influer sur la lecture du livre
certains gènes s'exprimeront d'autres
pas et heureusement je dirais parce que
tout n'est pas gravé dans notre adn et
un certain nombre de choses qui
dépendent de notre environnement et qui
dépendent aussi de notre libre arbitre
en quelque sorte et de notre façon de
vivre pour
que s'exprime une s'exprime pas ces
gènes bien
pour conclure je dirais que face à ces
technologies
il faut rester vigilant mais je dirais
aux citoyens que vous êtes ici
aujourd'hui réunies que pour paraphraser
un grand homme pas très grands
d'ailleurs je dirais n'ayez pas peur
mais rester vigilants quand même en tant
que citoyen parce qu'on peut faire des
tas de choses avec cette technologie
bonne ou mauvaise et enfin pour conclure
je citerai un grand physicien qui
s'appelait niels bohr et kddi la
prévision est difficile surtout celle de
l'avenir merci